in pittsburgh with antonio brown gone
and chris yesterday we did a draft of
the achilles heels that can affect the
various teams and and i said the number
two receiver in pittsburgh could be an
achilles heel because number one we
don't know who the hell it's gonna be
and number two there may be more
pressure on that guy than there was on
juju smith schuster last year because we
don't know whether or not juju smith
schuster can blossom into the number one
receiver that antonio brown was and
smith shuster says he is working on
catching balls down the field the free
balls they send down the field i got to
make those plays that's what i focused
on a lot catching the ball over the
shoulder and being able to be a threat
on the outside well if that's something
you're working on
that doesn't give me a whole lot of
confidence you're going to be able to do
it you're working on it that's good but
you shouldn't have to work on it it
already should be part of your game and
to just take juju smith schuster and
plug him from number two to number one
and put two guys on him all the time and
expect him to do the things that antonio
brown did i don't know that that's as
easy as we think it's going to be no
disrespect to juju's skills and we've
seen number twos try to become number
ones in the past alvin harper it doesn't
always work and and
you know we're we're just assuming you
slide him into the top spot and
everything's going to be fine these
quotes from juju smith schuster at least
tell us chris
we need to watch we need to wait well it
is the area of his game that i would go
it's probably the least impressive right
he's big he's strong he can break
tackles you see a lot of great catches
over the middle but the one thing i
don't think he does to defenses
necessarily is scare them with the deep
threat especially when he's on the
outside he doesn't have that type of
speed so i think he's trying to say yeah
he's working on that he realizes he's
going to be more of that
oh it's man-to-man big ben's just going
to throw it up to me now instead of
antonio brown and he wants to get better
at you know those balls that yes i am i
am tightly covered but you know big ben
puts a ball out here and i adjust the
proper way or puts it behind my back and
i can go get it that way so i i
understand that aspect he's just trying
to let you know he's working on that as
some area that he thinks he needed to be
better but i think that is the biggest
question mike about juju smith schuster
is can he scare people with the nine
route the go route can he back them off
consistently enough to where then it
opens up everything else underneath
because guys are fearful he'll he'll
catch a bomb over their head from big
ben
and and i just want and again juju smith
schuster is a young guy and i love him
he's a great player i love his passion
for the game i don't know that i would
be sharing publicly anything that would
suggest i don't have utmost confidence
in my ability to do it that i'm working
on i just don't know that i want the
world to know that right now i don't
know how do you feel about that aspect
yeah i i i understand you but you're
saying i think you're right i probably
would not have said that either that
would probably be one i would just have
you know kept under wraps not even
brought attention to it or anything like
that because two hey you can't just
guarantee that every team's amazing at
scouting and they're gonna put
everything together right this might
open some eyes up to where some teams go
you know
wait that is right i mean now that i
look at them he doesn't win a lot on the
outside and just blow by people and it
might change the approach of a coaching
staff or corners what's going to happen
in 17 days the steelers go to new
england step on gilmore see exactly what
juju smith schuster has said so what are
they going to do they're going to take
away his ability to run the routes that
he is comfortable running and they're
going to force him to do the things that
he's working on because they know he's
got less confidence in that he'd prefer
not to do that they're going to force
him to prove that he can and that may be
one of the ways that you slow down a
juju schmidt schuster in week one of his
experiment as the number one receiver in
pittsburgh uh yes definitely and i would
hope pittsburgh would know enough to go
hey this is not exactly the a plus part
of his game
and move him around let him work the
middle of the field let him catch
shallow crossers and you know
deep crossers across the middle in cuts
like that that's really where he is
awesome but still i think there's enough
talent there ultimately to scare people
away on that go route to where it'll be
effective enough to where it helps out
the rest of the game the rest of the his
game and the offense in general
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports